some buffers have given me some
incredibly valuable information which
I'll show you guys on footage soon but
I'm gonna have to be a bit careful
because Disney has been taken down these
videos like the apocalypse but there was
actually a leaked extended trailer of a
circuit solar celebration and we have so
much new footage from this in this video
I'll be showing and talking about Sabine
using Ezra's lightsaber and I gotta say
she looks damn good with green the
lightsaber really suit to her and it
looks like she can use it well which
makes sense because she practiced with
the dark saber and Star Wars Rebels
before but anyway Sabine here A Knight's
editor is green lightsaberge and we see
a villain holding a red lightsaber where
we can't see who they are just yet as
they're not in frame fully and then we
cut that mid shot of sabini holding the
green lightsaber and it does look damn
good but then that person ruled in the
red lightsaber is revealed as a clash
blade in the sequence here and it is
revealed to be this dark Jedi type
person that we saw in the official
release trailer on YouTube but one
interesting thing to note is that in
this sequence here Sabine is actually
not wearing armor and she's also
donating a longer hairstyle as opposed
to her Rebel look however at the end of
this trailer there was actually a little
sequence after the title which shows
Ahsoka wearing a different outfit and
Sabine donor the shorter hairstyle so it
seems later in this series she will get
a haircut again so I'm guessing this
might be towards the star of the series
and perhaps she's not wearing armor
because she might have been caught off
guard so she quickly looked around to
grab the lightsaber to fight off this
person but it wasn't really like a plan
thing and she wasn't expecting you know
trouble to come away so she just wasn't
in the armor but but there's just
speculation and there might be a
completely different reason but let me
know what you guys think in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed videos
like this please tell me in the comment
section below and I'll do more of them
thanks for watching guys